sherry and oversight committees did the
attorney general have any satisfactory
answers for your questions congressman
absolutely not john in fact he couldn't
address how many arrests how many people
have been prosecuted under our
immigration laws he can't tell us how
many people are wandering around the
country with removal orders he couldn't
answer anything pertaining to that but
somehow john he found the ability to
personally as he said personally work on
that memorandum to uh go after parents
at school board meetings it's absolutely
incompetence and it's more than that
it's it's a it's a dereliction of duty
in my opinion okay so why is the
administration willing to completely
look the other way as more that well
over a million people have just kind of
walked into our country
i'll give you two or three reasons
number one they campaigned on an open
border number two they said that they uh
they've indicated that they think that
these folks will end up voting democrat
at some point and that's part of why
they want to give amnesty to these
people which is ultimately a path to
citizenship and the third thing is
there's a lot of people that are in this
administration that don't believe in the
west valley nation state they don't
believe in the the concept of a nation
state i mean that's something that's
been a treasure on the left for a long
time to eliminate that so there's three
there's three reasons right there but
the bottom line is they all make our
country more insecure
and this is a national security issue
right now we want to put up the fiscal
year numbers from 2020 versus 21 2021
fiscal year ended in september
458 000 apprehensions at the border
last year this year 1 million
734
686 and those are just the apprehensions
there are
what tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands more who
came across the border but did not get
stopped
john that's right the estimate's at
least a half a million so we have known
godaways of about a thousand a day that
we know are getting into the country
then there's a whole lot of other people
we don't know how many get in we don't
know
where they're going we don't know where
they're coming from we don't know what
their intentions are and if they don't
if they're not surrendering because
right now everybody's surrendering
because they know they're going to be
released into the country most likely
if they're not surrendering they're
bringing probably drugs their their sex
trafficking their human trafficking and
and some people are actually on the
terrorist watch list that are coming
into our country while i was there a
week ago uh sitting having a meeting
with some border patrol uh leaders uh a
a fellow from syria came into the
country they that they apprehended so
this is a real issue
um john it's it's well over two million
people have come into the country
illegally this year where is the vice
president she's the one who's supposed
to be fixing this problem right
well she's she's supposed to be but
she's talking about climate change being
the root cause and the root cause she
would see better if she just look in the
mirror it's her and joe biden with their
horrible policies and their failure to
lead on this on this issue so um i'm
kind of glad that she's not more
involved because she tends to mess up
everything she touches meantime we've
got that huge caravan it's apparently
the the largest yet on its way
uh from i guess the southern part of
mexico on its way up uh and headed for
the border uh what what is the
administration doing to try to turn that
around
well as far as i know they're just
monitoring i mean which what we need is
we need a vigorous uh cooperative
relationship with the mexican government
the northern triangle states to actually
put down speed sticks for these caravans
like we had with president trump when he
got involved and worked with those
leaders they start started helping us
stop those care events these guys are
doing nothing they're kind of watching
i've met with border patrol agents in
different sectors over the last couple
weeks asking what are you going to do
they're they're putting together plants
but there's virtually not enough
personnel there's not enough facilities
to deal with this and we have to have
help from the mexican government and
and quite frankly it'd be nice to get
some help from our government leaders
too
republican congressman andy biggs of
arizona thank you
thanks john
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else